not good evening everybody my son didn't
give me agenda solving that having good
start with what emergency evacuation
announcement meeting we all do and
corded she'll be required to evacuate
the building you please leave the room
by the door to the fire escape their
casings please hold both handrails in
case the stairs and wet or slippery if
anybody's identities who says with a
clearly other switch in the room before
they go to the Fire Scout dog while it
can then be given assistance the
assembly point will be the puppet car
park at the side of the Civic sweet
don't delay your evacuation to collect
any belongings you don't return to the
building until you permission to do so
by the council's are pioneering use math
emergency evacuation answer will argue
my trusted I only should know by now
really like fightin one apologies for
absence like we had none on this point
in time at the moment right non-members
it Cena right there I one into
difficulties minutes of the meeting held
on the twenty-seventh of junior
which of course I wasn't that that's
right and will you give sir I was do you
think they were to wake up yes I don't
you also argue with it so I look up I
was here that awesome happy outside I
wanted to record yes I'm happy to do
that for you to do that
14 2015 this print my name is my
signature that it
right let me go I know any declarations
of interest no right last item on the
agenda which I suspect of Islam or
larger than the other fluid for show you
view management and your whip you what's
the format you give us the sort of intro
and then you're always kind of providers
with some questions which you had an
advance some go through those as a win
absolutely yeah ok so the report is is a
backward look of the year that we've
just closed 2014 15 I guess the the
highlighted bits to point out you're
probably going to have questions on
these but actual income made from
treasury management activities
thirty-eight thousand four hundred pound
as shown in paragraph one point to the
app three that would that be interest
payments that's purely interest accrued
from from you ask a few naive questions
but that's fine as a new boy yeah and
the position on the balance sheet is
dropped from just over two million to
just over one and a half million and I
can give reasons for that one long-term
investment is shown in paragraph 3.1
outstanding one and a half million
pounds which should be maturing at the
end of August current predictions are
that we will probably have to pull that
into short-term cash flow funding but
i'm going to monday down on that
table 4.3 just kind of highlight that
the return on interest how it just
continues to go down in 2013-14 we
received sick just over 60,000 pounds
and as a safe 38,000 just over four last
year so it's just a highlight really of
where we are with interest rates
nationally mr. Carney said today thought
they were going up I did hear and yes
which ad I've got fixed too so I I'll
hand it over to you whether you've got
questions I'm sure you have and we'll
we'll tackle them on my life so I off
them on behalf of the medial to take one
each what do you want to folks I've got
a particular question you got to you my
don't go first here and I'm 4.1 we
talked about the possibility of interest
rates rising and the charges are they
are going to you've estimated they're
going to go from point 5 to point seven
five but is that the opinion also of
capita that is capitis opinion okay
that's not my opinion that's capitis
opinion okay but does does the district
council agree with capitis just a little
you is taken out yeah I mean we can we
can only really go on historically where
capita of said we would be against where
we actually are over the years that
we've used them the trouble is because
we're in kind of unprecedented times of
interest rates and we have been over
five years as it we've been a half a
percent they've had a lot of I'll say
guesses but they're clearly logically
based assumptions the interest rates
were going to rise we're going to rise
and every few months now be put back put
back so all I can say really is that is
their latest forecast based on where
they sing the market being they do
benchmark themselves against other
financial institutions one of them is I
think the company called capital
economics in London and they tend to be
very similar in their forecasts so
personally give them what the governor
of the Bank of England said today I
would think what they're saying here
October 15 is a possibility that I
wouldn't like to you know on my company
tell about say we'd go up gradually not
provide too much a shot to the economy
yeah I think that obviously grace is it
is a big factor now we hope that
whatever deal they put a new place will
will be taken and the Greek economy can
then be left you know they can bring in
their austerity measures and can be left
to try and build things back up but if
if let's say if Greece do suddenly leave
the euro I don't think anyone really has
a clue what repercussions that's going
to have across the rest of it into it as
capita go of you on there they don't
like to say my first discipline I they
they don't say I'm sure they've got
personal views but again one thing is
for sure is that the interest rates can
only go in one direction only but I
think October myself is a little bit too
early for it to rise but we shall see
yeah yeah all right okay do you want to
address the questions around on the
paper that might not be yeah that's some
weeding them out even listening to this
yeah yeah okay if you play there's a
gate day that a good gear cuz I've got
some questions but I can see that
questions 1-3 are questions I've got
anyway so I suppose you go to uni and
Jamie with yeah I'm gonna just tell me
you're doing
those running suggestions yep it's devan
to ask your own questions but if you
hand guiding each other I think I've got
some more anyway probably going to cover
the same yeah I think I mean yeah one
and three are I have got here was pushed
inside that's fine is it best for
someone to read the questions over the
benefit of the tape yes yeah if I read
the question and then try and address it
and it so the first question was
relating to paragraph 3.1 what factors
have led to the fall imbalances over the
year from putting 0 14 million to 1.50 8
million well basically if I had this
report this time last year here in front
of me box 3.1 which shows our one
long-term investment this time last year
showed two and there was another one we
had of for 500,000 pounds that was on
investment i think for eight months
during the year that matured and we had
to pull it back in for short-term cash
flow reasons primarily to fund the
purchase of the waste vehicles went
towards purchasing which is another
question further now but didn't we were
we going to give her films alone for
that we internally borrowed for the
waste vehicles but in terms of actual
cash to pay the bills we needed to bring
that 500,000 into the bank balances so
if it was there to be used to pay
physically paid invoices and we did that
mature that account about the 500 of
them he matured and we talking on which
other day when did when was that I don't
know it was during I believe it was
I think it was februari but I can't be
sure i'll have to check it was within
the financial year 1415 once they would
have been after 35 smart what 2014 mmm
yes yeah be it would have been between
the first of april 2014 and the 31st mar
2015 because us i think it was februari
this year but I'll need to check out fit
really [ __ ] idea ok any other reasons at
all now that's purely purely it I mean
that then you say 500 6000 glasses and
yeah so its majority of it is that
500,000 so now interest you know what
the total cost was for the completion of
the bottom of the food truck yes I've
got well I've got the approved figure
that was in the capital program which
was 22 million three hundred and eighty
eight thousand seven hundred and eighty
two pounds I'm not sure he came in
exactly that but it was within that that
figure within about 50,000 of that
figure
time to move on number two graph after
paragraph four point to presume that the
peaks and troughs see relate to the
monthly collection of council tax and
then the payment of wages etc over the
month what do the higher spikes
represent and basically this is really
timing on specific income streams that
build up during the year now we have we
have regular income that comes in
monthly we have a Housing Benefit
subsidy of about million and our 1.5
million that comes in we have C council
tax income and business rate can come
that comes in three times a month so
we're the peaks are on the graph there
there where we've been able to build up
balances and you'll notice that the
curve is really going down throughout
the year and that that's really because
during the year balances have come down
and down down gradually but we still be
now to have those spikes where we've had
maybe one more half million two million
come in for a short period but then on
the 19th of the month which happens
every month we pay our preceptors we pay
patent with payroll comes out we have a
creditors run and it lifting wipes is
back out again and then it slowly builds
up so the three peaks are literally
where we've been out of build up and
build up and build up and then suddenly
it's all gone but those Peaks are
getting lower and lower and lower
because the average balance is getting
lower level so we sorry but we all know
they have long-term investments for the
fairly large sons there's always a
balance there in the books within the
current account yeah yes so do we get
any interest or do we get much of much
interest
we get our current account is with
Lloyds and they pose no point four
percent which etches and it sounds all
for it it's not too bad for an overnight
current account I tend to really so
those peeps are you would expect sealers
yes they are yeah a natural Peaks an
hour probably continuous even go into
the 2015 CN yeah yeah probably going to
have a similar thing those long legs
doing pigs but the pink we'll be getting
lower lower if you see well as much as
they'll be troughs as well getting
laughs and laughs okay yep paragraph 4.3
and the table there what was the cause
of the full in average balance over the
year from the graph above it seems the
reduction is fairly steady and basically
this is just just because we had a
gradual draw down on our balances over
the year it's not really relating to any
one particular item it's just the
expenditure as a whole the draw down on
our back on our balances that we have in
the current account in our short-term
investment account we could exclude the
long-term reversal everything that's
short term that we can pull straight
away to fund things has gradually just
been diminishing and that that ties in
really with the interest return that
we're getting I've said this before in
previous meetings but six seven years
ago when interest rates of five
five-and-a-half percent we could get by
five and a half percent from our banks
building societies we were getting
interest returns of niall a million
pounds so that million would have just
been pop straight back into investment
a year you were at least putting another
million in from return on investments
but now we just we don't see anything
near that 38,000 is the best presumably
as the council finance is getting
tighter this position will be squeezed
even more yes it will be barring a huge
interest interest rates spike which is
unlikely but but yet the squeeze is on
now and this is something that we've
been in discussions quite heavily with
with with a milder chief exec and the
directors recently and our assistant
director finance really trying to plan
ahead for the next 2-3 years what we're
going to do because potentially we could
get to the stage where these balances
will run dangerously low and then we'll
be looking tomorrow unless new income
streams come on board but that's all in
discussions at the moment through
however the corporate plan for the
authority where where that vision is
paragraph 4.4 and the graph above it
presuming that before in the average
rate around August relates to the
maturity of the lloyds deposit and then
reinvestment of the same base rate has
been half a percent for the last few
years and previously Lloyds were
offering 1.01 do we know from capita
what factors led to Lloyd's only
offering point nine five percent and
presumably the market offering less of a
return for this deposit barclays bank
reserve and handles bank and reserve
accounts respectively provided an actual
rate point six five percent and point
seven percent assuming base rate at half
a percent so in fact the question is
really why why has our long-term
investments dropped from offering a rate
of over one percent and now below one
person it literally come to ask after
this one and it literally comes down to
interbank lending rates so where their
rates are increasing on borrowing
between each other they obviously have
to pass those costs on to us or we get
less of a rate on rate return home or on
our investments having said that nor
point nine five percent with Lloyds is
wide foot for 365 days days is why above
anywhere else we get the next best was
nationwide about point seven five
percent very nearby the interest rates
are going to go up or we feel they're
going to go up would it be best to wait
until I do to have any long-term fixed
investments so we can take it all at
least not commit ourselves to a long
period of time and wait for the interest
rates to rise yeah so so with the one
and a half million which is really all
we have to play with at the moment that
matures end of August
yeah 28 of august so when we get closer
to that date next month we will have to
consider all our options but definitely
I personally I need to speak to
assistant director yesterday from him
but I wouldn't want to be putting that
away for a year if clearly capita saying
interest rates under lights Orizon
particularly today around what the Bank
of England upset so we make no nearer
then what rates are going to do as it's
getting closer to october where
character is saying but I would think we
need to keep that as short-term as
possible with freight society going to
spike up hopefully by then the situation
in Greece which could have an effect yep
worldwide maybe clear up yeah there is
also the possibility we may need to pull
most of that one-half million if not
some of that to top up our balance is
because they're diminishing so much
literally just to pay our bills again
that's a discussion is to take place
because we could leave that and invest
it and if rates in good yet invested and
we could borrow to pay our bills or we
pull that and continue to be debt free
but still we have to pay our bills so
then it's the clearly be some thoughts
are our lands and decisions made us as
we get nearer to office quite worried
because we have to keep a minimum
reserve don't we on overtime yeah we
have to have a reserve but in terms of
reserves in our balance sheet they're
different to cash so cash if you look at
cash what we have in the bank or what we
have on long-term investment isn't
reflected that is not there's no
correlation between that and the 2.1
million pounds
for the amount reserves we have
unbalanced which bands literally a
figure on the balance sheet that is
there to fund future activities whereas
this is cash to fund paying our bills
that daily monthly wood table I saw a
question number five table in paragraph
five concerning capital expenditure the
question is what did we not buy in
2014-15 that we had budgeted for well
then I've been through our capital
program in terms of what we budgeted and
what we actually spend and there's not
really one particular item it's really a
whole stack of under Spence against most
planned works that will now be rolled
into this final financial year but I can
happily go through them one by one but
it's up to you i don't mind it might be
measured if you know I means the order
of how much savings would you better
just tell us the main few that the
because I yes I bigger just use the PM
ok so I T strategy had approved a budget
of a hundred and four thousand pounds we
only spent eighteen thousand of that
hundred and four thousand one hundred
thousand sorry over 104,000 most of it
budget was allocated to ensure the
council has had adequate IT data storage
facilities and I've been told that that
has now been rolled into 2015-16 because
they were adequate during the year so
that's going to be looked at again for
this year do you want to know what the
potential budget was approved budget is
for this year don't just keeping long
last year's thoughts or I confuse things
yeah sort of out whether or not that was
a bad estimate on the behalf of somebody
or else I figure we've kind of you know
managed to get away with this year but
actually it's going to come back yeah
good question suitable difference
between that so either someone got him
very wrong in the first place yeah look
what we've been very lucky and we're
going to get hit I think in terms of the
capital program the way it was the
capital program was set by our
predecessor section 1.1 officer bob
woodward who left the authority as part
of the redesign in the new year now she
obviously put the capital program
together based on what key officers were
telling her from the bits that were put
in and i personally I I think that a lot
of these projects have slipped into this
year purely because of a redesign
because key personnel have left me I
think we lost most of our senior
management team we lost most of our
middle managers and these were the
people on the ground who would have been
making sure these capital projects
happens so I think most of these
projects are now being looked at by the
new structure teams are the directors
and the assistant directors so I don't
think it's so much poor budgeting I
think it's poor timing really on the
fact that we just didn't the timing of
staff leaving and new stuff coming on
board and understanding their service
areas that they're responsible for these
areas are only now really beginning to
be looked at again which is why all of
these underspend to be rolled into this
financial year will say them they'll
have to be reserved again English funny
yeah but they're not lost so basically
what happens with the capital program
any understand any under spends will
just be rolled into 2015 16 and those
projects will be looked at in the here
and it may well be that that some of the
assistant directors in post now say well
actually what my predecessor said we're
going to do I don't want to do I don't
feel we need to do but they're looking
at those items as part of their service
review doing the longer you respond
doing things with the squeeze on
finances the less chance there is when
forgive me I don't understand too much
about government clients but can you
sort of course subsidy between capital
and revenue always that no no no you
capitalist a mark capital expenditure
expenditure cannot be used for revenue
projects you can use revenue funding to
top up capital space but not vice versa
so what's in the money that earmarked in
the capital program is capital money and
so anything that not that that's not
spending will it should just be rolled
into the following year and added to the
following years budgets and they will
just keep rolling in 10 tennis shoes
we've got some sort of men do you
flexibility to a lady wearing false yeah
yeah absolutely let me highlight some of
the other main ones the council's depo
down in rockford had a 60,000 pound
budget to look at and I don't know if
you're aware but back in he was at the
beginning of 2014 when we had that
floods locally and yep I was badly
affected so money was put into capital
program to to rectify that but then I
think it came in and back and forth
through council various times the floor
a natural way for Don the depo has been
agreed so that just got rolled into this
year I believe it has been agreed now
what they're going to do and the new
budget for this year's actually 400,000
so appears the project is a lot bigger
than what I planned originally anyway
damaged out without song I've been
covered by insurance yes and we had
faulty about 49,000 pounds back in
insurance to cover it but I think what
they're the par the plans are now is
well ok we could we could build like for
life but surely it's going to flood
again so I think now they can sit
been putting on stilts and all sorts of
things so hence the budgets go up to
400,000 so that was that I was a big
underspend car parks 20,000 pound budget
1,900 pounds spent was that mountain it
says here is for lighting upgrades and a
general program of works because I don't
get involved in and near the capital
meetings with the heads of service I
don't know what the capital program they
would have would have been but I guess
yeah it's probably just a general
upgrade program for our car parks and
again that's been rolled into this year
and added to this year's budget before
they rolled into this year's budget they
know all these items looked at a fresh
directive decide whether we need them
well initially the finance team will
roll them in automatically but meetings
are actually beginning to happen now as
part of this year's revised budget
process that will address that very
question so they were look and so
actually you know you've rolled it but
we don't need it what we do needy and we
actually need more so yeah that's that's
all happiness making and will form part
of the 2015-16 if I was presumably any
decision before decisions made that will
come to full council given beyond own
gym process I'm not sure on revised
capital budgets we come into full counts
were revised revenue budgets I have to
check on ax I've never been part of that
process in this on the legend of the
council tip on next week yes I believe
there is yeah yeah i think a lot of one
will probably be the research in
line I know that the depo because it's
such a big contentious issue has been
through council many times keeps coming
back in but little like programs of
works when I roll I'm not sure if that
would will not but after check on
signage enhancements so this is where we
have a program to replace and upgrade
highway directional signage again it's
just a rolling programme of works that
was was in place with the previous ass
estates manager there was a nine
thousand pound budget 2,000 pounds spent
that's a highway signs yes so these are
highway signs that we look after sales
and there are some signs within the
district that we have responsibility for
yes that would include road names leave
sire and also the signs where you say
where it says welcome to watch with
district on all the boundaries that no
marina took into your standard highway
are nice be there it's not known as an
eyesore time I has we got involved in
that another perfect now again of course
responsible for some web post LOL yeah
in some of the footpaths between roads
we're responsible for them car park
lighting yeah so not a big budget but
nine thousand pound mine mine
nevertheless play spaces 28 and a half
thousand pound budget six and a half
thousand pounds spend again I don't know
what the programmer works was there but
it's been rolled into this year Cherry
Orchard country park 58 thousand pound
budget 47,000 pounds spend hotkey woods
40,000 pound budget 12,000 pounds spend
that says here relates mainly done
completed works for staff facilities
20,000 to develop
concessionary facilities so there's
obviously going to be some kind of
toilet facilities and mess room
facilities playing for staff down there
that hasn't happened legal services had
a 23 nine thousand pound budget for a
land purchase which didn't happen I
don't know where that was for we did
purchase him there and every week we
purchased some in interterra all the
chairs here but i'm not sure if it was
for an old boy wouldn't because that was
this year was you know thing we ballin
you know so that came out of the chariot
budget for the ball where i would have
been a capsule expense it would have
been on here unless it didn't the price
we pay didn't reach the bucket possibly
possibly but i'm assuming they're also
things like purchases that we possibly
wouldn't have budgeted for if we didn't
know about it because i think if i
recall it came up quite late in the day
of men so it could be possibly of not
actually but should were originated
because we had no idea i'm sure the
cherry orchard latvian we bought that
this financially we did have a budget
for the cherry all do I've got the if i
remember right i thought it was quite
last-minute you know it was enticing me
just have this opportunity though this
was the one that was owned by the water
board or some yeah yeah buy it or lose
it or thing yeah resumen of that budget
won't be moved forward witness now it
has a basement
it's a nation that was a one-off but
with no spend and then probably the
biggest on their we budget three hundred
thousand pound a year for disabled
facility grants and only spent two
hundred and two thousand and I the
reason for that was because there was
nobody in the department for about three
months and purely staff vacancies but
Alice excitement there wasn't starved so
staff so what exactly so so the budget
wasn't fully used up because it wasn't
softened to administer that expenditure
because what it when that for that
budget to be used its means tested it
requires an officer to go out assess the
house that where they may get an
application from do they require it and
when you haven't got people on the
ground to do that auditory doesn't
happen so residents must do hmm yeah
although we now have someone in place
and that is being talked into this year
and has it been increased for this year
yeah she's only there will be a backlog
of the fringe loop stuff that won't get
any any younger spends on that lot of
that cat disabled facilities and for
home maintenance and adaptation grants
which is a separate ranbir similar to
disable facility rob is just roll every
year it's never decrease it sorta rolled
in and there's two to full time it was
stuff in there now dedicated to that
function okay so those those are the
main items causing under under spend on
the capital program thank you
questions6 has the purchase of the
refuse trucks been completed and if so
was it by using cash balances rather
than borrowing if cash balances reduce
overtime will we still be able to borrow
to finance this purchase we did purchase
the waist vehicles we purchased the last
of them in light june so they're all on
board now how many of it how many in
terms of total vehicles percentages have
been thoughtfully because it is their
complete to be proposed a bib room
everything yeah there's about 20 I got
up here notice parties have gotten off I
do so how do we pay for it well we we
used our own cash we didn't borrow we
didn't go out and get a loan we use
their own cash we built up our cash
balances and paper them ourselves what
we did have to do though is ensure an
overdraft was in place on our current
account that if we needed to dip into it
we could not just to pay for the waste
vehicles but because we obviously have
our continuing monthly payments that we
have to make that I mentioned before so
we arranged with Lloyds and overdraft
for six months cost of 5,000 pound and
we dipped into it four times so far that
will the deal with Lloyds was that will
go back when that million and a half
pounds matures they felt that as that
would be maturing we wouldn't need it
we've got the caveat to bring that back
in if we want to and how much was over
door for 5,000 pound coasters for a 2
million pound over
but we've only gone as I say we got into
it four times I think with the maximum
we went 900,000 for a night overdraw and
topped it back on the next day so it's
really to get us through our monthly ups
and downs from that graph of money
coming in and out ironically that then
reduces their own interest on
investments doesn't it yes so you all be
here though yeah yeah but going back to
the vehicles in a seat are responsible
for the maintenance of those ongoing
maintenance or of we got a liability I
believe they are responsible for the
upkeep of the maintenance of them as
loves written into the contract and
we've also seen the revenue saving on
the contract for providing them with our
own vehicles so there's a 200,000 pounds
aving on the road you'll see in the
budget of this year on the revenue side
of things but that unfortunate i'm in a
little bit later as well because the
original thought process from the waist
team was that we would have the vehicles
from the first of april so the contract
was budgeted to reduce from the first of
april but if that we didn't get all the
waste levels until the end of june so
two hundred thousand pound will be head
slightly probably by about 30,000
because of my just what got this right
in my head the total cost of these
vehicles was approximately two point
three million yeah which we pay for cash
we used a big chunk of our reserves up a
patient says yes and in order to do that
we then had to take an overdraft of two
million pounds which cost us five
thousand man yes rather than going out
borrowing for a year so two million
pounds
that was the cheaper option we've
usually ever drove always half years do
you drop so now our jobs are going to
both be paid off when this while the
able job the overdraft is in place so we
can deep into the air drafters maintain
so if for example win this investment of
1.5 matures on the twenty eighth of
august yet if we are half a million
pounds in overdraft 500,000 of this
investment would be used to pay that
overdraft offs that we didn't have that
of any longer potentially or we could
renegotiate another overall length on
the overdraw but i think we probably
want to pay on a work effort things off
financial flips one we did all the all
the calculations in terms of comparing
our trough to gain a larger there's a
lot cheaper to pay five thousand bound
for an overdraft than to have a loan for
a year but we have been doing so left
ourselves with extremely low reserved
we've left us alone well we've left
ourselves with low cash balances but
that was a great last year to do it that
way to self-finance the most vehicle
okay welcome now you're welcome King
James trying to understand and absorb
them yeah I think there was a report
that came into Council a waste contract
yeah he got became some good BP and
Sarah yeah I mean I don't need to ask
questions about that it was Justin least
you're trying to work in my head whether
that made sense to me yeah but the time
they looked at the purchase that the
Vice vehicles it was looked at leasing
costs because they're in the capita and
she got examples of racing costs and got
there a lot of work on there to see if
it were better at least the vehicles and
it went on quite a bit yeah which was
the most favorable method I know the
section 151 opposition up to every
viable option which was leasing
externally borrowing or internally
boring
internal boring was the cheapest option
it came from a recommendation from
review committee of course to purchaser
vehicles in front yeah before what I
think the reason was when fountain had
the grounds maintenance contract and
then went into administration we had no
vehicle sir we were stumped and at that
point they realized if Sita there any
reason when the same ye and they had
vehicles would have nothing to do refuse
collections with it was decided it would
be better for us driving the vehicles
let say to use them and maintain them
but if anything happened to Satan during
the time of the contract we would have
the vehicles be able to continue the
refuse collections otherwise we wouldn't
have any answer the logic behind
haunting and purchasing our own yeah i
think possibly it's just the way it's
been financed what other you know for me
there's a concern that really with
regards to the future of it and the fact
that how low these could possibly go and
i thought you know in hindsight when I
was one thing but I'm kind of thinking
well the total cost was 2.3 million
which we paid in cash but possibly now
gonna lose some of the 1.5 if we should
be over drawn in paying that off it
costs us 5,000 pound to arrange that if
we'd have kept in perhaps arranged it
another way and we would still have that
investment now we've been about it we
would but you've also got a very mind
that if let's say we externally borrowed
we would have to pay back that loan at
some stage it's only been probably if
we'd have done here we'd have probably
done over five years or so no boring but
there would have been interest payments
to pay that back every every three
months or six months or if we did it
every year we don't be final at any
years time so I think that I mean I'm
sure that I'm sure at the time the
decision was yeah
I'm sure there's scrutinize but I mean
I'm looking at our cash flow forecasting
for the next six months I'm actually
quite that we won't buy by the time we
get to that lower than the the overdraft
ending in September our cash balances
will begin to climb again hopefully so I
think that one and a half million will
be at a reinvest we'll do whatever we
want whether I I'm hoping we're not
going to put a very busily as a
significant amount of a profile drop the
way I learned from the full cost was
looking at today on our system the one
on Hoffman you might be touched but
there is a risk that it could be oh no
we don't know what certainties lie ahead
there could be something that comes out
of the woodwork in the next three months
then we've got a fine cash for ya okay
yeah I do remember that under review
committee looked into it in great detail
because all recommending them we
purchase our our vehicles that's right
that's why two years ago I guess what
yeah that's what we first started
looking 18 2013 good but what is the
working life of these vehicles do we
know either I must feed the Marcus
cotton the assistant director for
Environmental Services the other day and
he was saying I think anything between
seven and ten years so potentially in
seven to 10 years ago after consider our
options again so is this something we
could budget for over seven and ten
years we need to instead of doing it all
on year cigs yeah and trying to find
that absolute are we already looking for
something well as yeah marker that's par
Moxie's rail reason to start considering
that for a project play planning placed
at what we're going to do I think about
what we're going to dairy 16 years
doctor couldn't put something in the
budget though for each you cut on a
cubed live basis for the kooza can we
come in well we could put revenue if we
if our revenue receipts build up we can
put revenue receipts away to reserve
actually puts I dupatta money if we can
both see our revenue finances are being
here as well and that's all depending on
where the government funding in the next
coupla months so there's gonna be
interesting questions that are we seeing
any significant changes in the market
due to the uncertainty over the
situation with Greece undoubtedly there
are uncertainties daily with within the
whole eurozone because of what's
happening with Greece and it's have
enough i fix wider than eurozone as well
if you regulate china lost weakness not
market collapse pretty horrendous linea
in terms of our exposure because of the
risk criteria and risk selection process
we take we have no direct exposure with
Greece so that's the good news obviously
though if problems continue in Greece
that he's just going to have a continued
downward effect on interest rates as a
whole across the eurozone so it could
potentially impact some of the banks
that we do even i'm thinking
particularly someone like handles
banking a Swedish Bank that we've got
balances with who pay a pretty good
interest rate I daresay they must have
investments in the wider european market
so because i literally I just think to
be the only ones lending in a minute oh
no don't know
you're Clanton I have lots of mine now
the names are changing on whose
interests jyoti that is always the
angles banking but again that particular
question it says something you can take
advice on for the capita put two in
terms of exposure yeah or your the
exposure to foreign banks yeah so when I
when I chat to our relationship manager
weekly and when they send us credit
rating reports day and when they look at
our investments monthly they give us
kind of a risk measure if you like on
where I balances are at and they deem us
to be as safe as you can be where we
glad so so acacia the moment is in
Lloyds current account where the
overdraft is if it's not your overdraft
it's in surplus we have a Barclays
reserve account which is only got ten
thousand bound in it and we have the
handles banking is over camp we have
access to use money market funds and
other banks and building societies
Bertha moment that's all yeah purely
because we have no cash that's the only
place where we played one of them you
don't want you know that I'm sorry no no
I mean capita as a sigh capita
provider's credit updates on a daily
basis and that isn't kind of just
reactive as well they will give us
warnings they will build the picture up
the more they know about institutions
they'll build up daily but they they're
telling
handles bankers I placed of where that
leaves onto a question if I may yep yep
because obviously we need to use capital
and I think it's a good thing that we
take our advice yeah or we don't have to
take that advice we listen to the advice
of the make no decision and they only
charge 6,000 pounds a year but I do
remember the review committee some time
ago talking as to whether capita can do
more for us another I'm not sure he'll
help where that was taken well we
invited Richard bison who's our
relationship manager in to give a
training session where members were
given the opportunity to basically see
what more they could offer I don't know
if you were there I while I'm ahead I
don't think I believe that most other
company was the items up to wider
Council think it was here was there all
councillors cows home last year was yeah
yeah name debossed I've been going the
aims October yeah so the short answer
the question is yes they can offer us
why we want obviously that has a cost
they're giving us everything they can
within the 6,000 pound that moment
anything further will add cost can they
offer us anything more that would save
us money not that I know of they always
say we're doing well with what we've got
yeah 36 hours of pent seems a fair price
to be fair yeah yeah i mean just talk
about because this is a sectional
highlight as well the 6,000 pounds beard
I suppose actually looking at the
contrast iron rule is that a fixed
contract for certain period of time has
it been reviewed whimsical I'll show
dude and peace it's a five-year contract
and it was last reviewed even January to
14 so we're just coming into the second
so we are heavily reliant on them
advising us phone because I've seen it
really we only take our decisions based
on their advice if we don't have anybody
not one hundred percent so we use a lot
of our own knowledge and skills we've
quite skilled finance team it's a cough
yes don't get me wrong if we didn't have
capital we would have to do a lot of
work ourselves in terms of looking at
credit ratings looking at sovereign
ratings etc and they do honor that that
6,000 our service provides all of that
and they provide credit watches they can
provide credit updates they put our
stuff on training courses they will come
and they phoned me once a week they
cover mean the senior team twice a year
so we go out of the six thousand pound
they're quite proactive yeah absolutely
and and as soon as something happens
they'll be on the phone saying right
have you considered this maybe you want
to think about this they'll do a balance
sheet review of a bunchy as well so
personally having our group has to dry
that it's good value for mine but yeah
and I'd add that there is quite a bit of
work that my team do if we give written
Iceland the Iceland problem
however many years ago that was at the
time a few weeks before that Kappa tear
or sectors they were was saying that it
was a safe haven really but we as an
authority through through things up a
bit so we'll hang on a minute why they
paid two percent more than anywhere else
this is a bit crazy so we didn't put
that money there and I'm really just
through reading financial papers and
abusing our own skills and knowledge we
we didn't I'm really capita did
eventually before happened they did say
look we think Cal solution pull out and
advise that but we didn't have anything
else we didn't need to worry come on
that same sentence one coming up I
noticed in the reports is that the
cancer contract costs six thousand per
year this represents a good value for
money for your thority as we have
achieved better results than we might
have how do we know that I'm based on
what do kept to provide some sort of
report that says if you had a done this
or you would have got this return so can
we actually definitely prove that's
that's what that sentence really is
based on benchmarking against like other
local authorities if we took someone
like parcel point who use character as
well they chose they choose to ignore
captors advice and they just put
everything in the debt management office
with the government under north point
two five percent so where we take
captives advice and investing in
low-risk safe triple-a rated with Double
A rated areas we've achieved 30 and a
half thousand on a seminary if they had
a similar investment might have been
achieving other than a few thousand so
it's based that sense is really based on
benchmark in further questions so do one
of those comments for the question and
on point to point to and top of a 25
point to the very last sentence it says
all executive decision on foreign
investment or finance are delegated the
assistant director Sam but should that
not be in conjunction with the portfolio
holder and thing is dangerous to have
that delegated to one person I know is
could a team behind him you got support
of capita but I thought that would have
been done in with in conjunction with
the portfolio holder that sentence
errors is literally just changed from
saying the head of finance both people
to whether it was the head of financing
on woodward or this isn't director for
resources Joseph Reverend room they're
both the council section 151 officer so
that's why josephs role title has been
replaced from what reforms title was and
that's written down in our Constitution
that he's the one point one officer and
has ultimate responsibility for finances
for the authority
but we can we can't change it because he
doesn't obviously speak to counselor
Smith over all these matters so you
could change it to say that in
conjunction with and people per year
older I feel as happy with that yes that
would give those equal protection as
well when the people are just tell me
William hmm no that sentence is bugging
me that I'm not certain I think it's
more statement that this one about it
represents his value for money I would
like up with the third say something
along the lines of you know it's our
opinion that this represents good
service might be based on the other
service the proactiveness of capitals
and another I think dirty say this
represents good value for money for the
authority as we've achieved better
results than we might have just find
that same in a bit your concern is no
proof of that is correct and we know I
know we take cash with advice but as if
this time we do have a good team so this
isn't a person to you obviously the exam
p.m. the example you gave their about
invisible point investing their money in
some government scheme that gets a
lonely term well I would hope we
wouldn't do that if our finance team
what that good i would hope that they
would make those decisions not to do
that anyway so or just make it clear run
what that sentence is supposed to say
and i would add the a difference to do
with comparative neighboring yeah I
vulgarities perhaps just maybe make that
up I mean overall I had noted here that
actually I didn't have an issue with
recommending the content of this
reportable counsel but that one sentence
for me is can changing parts all in
convergys it tweaked so if I change you
later in our opinion this for years but
yeah I just think it's all could you've
actually made
from benchmarking the authorities
dumbbell yeah yeah to something like
that thing heavy how is your take into
account benchmarking another authorities
yep something like that yeah i mean i
would you feel more comfortable just a
guess that explains it a bit better yeah
if someone from an outside was looking
at document and saw that you know to say
this represents good value for money
it's only going to take one person to
try and dig out yes i'm on the free at a
similar service for half the amount of
money something like that so naughty
I've got no issue with captain I've got
no issue with really generally the
concerts report up but just prefer that
okay okay chairman you're happy for me
to come on you know i would add just for
the purposes of the type of the castle
point put their money in the debt
management office purely insane minimize
all risk then the name Saul gives you
away leave yes yeah and I'm so we're
going to recommend that the pauper he
orders yes is consulted yes yes yes if
you've got a screw you man I have I will
change that he said Ogden I think Elena
is yep thank you much for your
contributions colleagues and thank you
thanks Paul and thanks madam so if we
got Spanish Inquisition below as yeah
that's cool you did well make yes you
had all the answers what okay